despite releasing a full 15 years later
you could argue that the Callisto
protocol is a spiritual successor to
Dead Space given the original pitch from
director Glenn Schofield was for
visceral games's survival horror title
to be set within a prison not a mining
vessel and in a lot of ways the Callisto
protocol similarly dazzles with its
incredible art Direction and sound
design even emulating dead spaces over
the shoulder third-person perspective
and integrated HUD however the Callisto
protocol goes Its Own Way by focusing on
melee strikes and Dodges utilizing a
combat system that feels great at first
but isn't suitable for the game's more
action-focused latter half plus lengthy
death animations compound the
frustrations of surprise difficulty
spikes creating an experience that feels
like an uneven mix of horror and action
that fails to adequately commit or excel
at either
oh
in the Callisto protocol you play as
Jacob Lee a freight transporter
contractor to Ferry cargo for the United
Jupiter company moving supplies from the
ujc operated black Iron prison on
Callisto to the Colony on Europa on a
routine trip back to black Iron Jacob's
ship is boarded by outer way a group
blamed for a recent terrorist attack on
Europa in the ensuing struggle Jacob and
the outer way leader Danny Nakamura are
the only survivors stranded on Callisto
they're both picked up by black iron
security head captain Leon Ferris and
incarcerated in the prison on orders
from Warden Duncan Cole Jacob awakes in
Black Iron hours later discovering a
mysterious disease has been released
into the prison transforming the
prisoners and guards into biophage
monsters escaping from his cell he teams
up with fellow prisoner Elias Porter to
find a way out look this place can mess
with your head this is our chance
whatever it was you saw it's all the
more reason to get out of it the
Callisto protocol doesn't devote too
much time to storytelling and World
building none of the characters say
foreign are especially likable and
though the main villain has an
intriguing motivation it's only revealed
right as the game is concluding I wish
it had been revealed far sooner because
though the ramifications of it are
interesting there's not enough space in
the plot for those ramifications to be
explored the game fleshes out the world
up to that point with optional audio
logs to discover but most of them don't
actually reveal all that much and those
that do aren't very interesting to
listen to it's ultimately not worth
going off the path in pursuit of these
collectibles
[Music]
the Callisto protocol features a combat
system heavily focused on melee attacks
and dodging while also keeping a careful
eye on resources and health this
encourages a hyper aggressive fighting
style by getting within clawing range of
the threat and overwhelming them with a
quick but controlled beating is the key
to success
dodging is fairly simple to pull off
they'll curiously assigned to the same
stick used to control Jacob's movement
not only do you use the left stick on a
controller to move Jacob but pushing it
left to right as enemies attack is how
you Dodge in either direction and
one-on-one Encounters this isn't too
much of a problem you're facing the
threat at hand and moving or dodging
accordingly but it becomes unmanageable
when confronted with larger groups of
enemies when you're surrounded by
multiple biophages turning to keep track
of an enemy could cause you to dodge an
attack from a different enemy instead
potentially repositioning you into a
disadvantaged corner and twisting the
camera away from the threat you're
trying to track it doesn't happen every
time but it happens enough to be
frustrating and in a game as difficult
as the Kalisto protocol losing track of
your positioning even for a moment can
result in taking game over inducing
damage
the integrated HUD works against the
Callisto protocols combat in this regard
much like dead space the Callisto
protocol doesn't feature a traditional
user interface instead Jacob's health is
conveyed via the life support system
grafted to the back of his neck and
instead of an ammo counter at the bottom
corner of the screen it's displayed as a
holographic projection on whichever Gun
Jacob is holding in a game like dead
space where protagonist Isaac Clarke is
battling Necromorphs from a controlled
distance it's a lot easier to quickly
glance at the displays on Isaac's armor
and keep an eye on the approaching
Necromorphs weighing the situation
against your current health and ammo
account it also helps that Isaac doesn't
really move when firing any of his
weapons managing to keep all his systems
in Clear View at all times but in the
Callisto protocol Jacob is moving around
a lot more twisting his body as he
Dodges attacks or swings his stun baton
within the throes of a Close Quarters
combat encounter it's difficult to keep
track of your resources because not only
is the threat at hand more immediate the
display is detailing relevant
information are moving around more if
happen to miss that your health bar has
reduced from a healthy green to a
flashing red in the midst of a fight
you'll be unaware that the next hit you
suffer will likely be your last
okay the biofages hit hard and fast most
of the Callisto protocols horror comes
from the unskippable death animation
you're subjected to when Jacob dies all
of which are gruesome but after the
second or third time one happens these
death animations lose their shock factor
and become tedious if you're stuck on
one difficult combat encounter or
challenging boss fight they're quite
frustrating the first time I saw Jacob's
head getting caved in I grimaced but by
the third or fourth time I just wanted
the game to load the encounter again
I've seen Jacob die it's gross I get it
don't waste my time and just let me try
again or at least allow me to skip any
death animations I've already seen it's
irksome that the Callisto protocol
really only horrifies through failure
there's nothing about the actual
experience that's all that scary save
from the gruesome nature of how Jacob
can die which only curates irritation
not fear
the Callisto protocol opts for cheap
jump scares way more often than it
should even repeating the same scares
numerous times some of these I do like
hearing a biophage rummaging through the
vents and desperately turning Every
Which Way in a vain attempt to track it
only for it to burst out of the floor
behind me is a thrill but having a
little screaming slug burst out of a
closed Locker a dozen times across the
entirety of the game is a bit much
having it happen once or twice would
have been enough to make me wary of
opening Lockers in search of ammo but
the actual frequency only ensured I
expected it always to happen and if
scare isn't all that scary when you're
already expecting it
as you continue to explore black Iron
you'll find blueprints for new Firearms
allowing Jacob's Arsenal to evolve
through the magic of black Iron's
futuristic 3D printers alongside the
stun baton Jacob acquires a host of
firearms and the grip device which is a
gravity manipulating Gauntlet used by
black Iron guards that Jacob repurposes
as a weapon
around the time you acquire the grip
device the Calypso protocols combat is
at its absolute best you're repeatedly
threatened with two or three
hard-hitting enemies at a time and your
trusty sidearm and grip device can give
you great crowd control when your
Dodgers won't cut it alone new avenues
of combat open up with the addition of
these weapons too Landing several melee
attacks on an enemy in a row will
temporarily stun them for example
opening them up for a Precision shot
from your firearm that deals extra
damage and can carve off arms or legs of
your foes this can significantly alter
your situation a bio phase without legs
will have to slowly crawl its way
towards you for instance while one
missing an arm doesn't have as much
offensive potential alternatively the
grip can be used to pick up and launch
biophages into environmental hazards
like spinning fan blades or Spike line
walls there's an especially cool moment
where Jacob has to fight his way down a
hallway as enemy steadily approach from
the other side one by one and
methodically pushing through them with
murderous swings of the stun baton a few
well placed shots and the occasional use
of the grip is exhilarating the game
sadly never quite delivers on the thrill
of that moment ever again but it's a
shining example of what the Callisto
protocol could have been throughout its
run time instead about Midway through
the Callisto protocol you start facing
much larger groups of enemies in wider
spaces where biophages come at you from
multiple sides and the games carefully
curated combat quickly devolves reducing
your options in combat to mindlessly
swinging and quickly blasting off a
Precision shot when the indicator pops
up as enemies grow more plentiful Jacob
starts finding Firearms with wider and
harder hitting bullet spreads like a
shotgun and railgun encouraging you to
abandon Precision even further in favor
of just dealing damage as quickly as
possible in order to survive it's not
especially challenging to Simply swing
with abandon Dodge when you can shoot
your gun without really aiming and hope
for the best and it's not very fun
either
foreign
[Music]
the Precision shot suffers in these
situations as well the mechanic is
designed to reward quick reflexes and of
course precision as you only have a
brief moment to pull it off before an
enemy recovers it's mechanically simple
to do but between Jacob's movement and
the constant squirming of enemies the
auto aim feature can't reliably snap
your aim to where a Precision shot
should land an enemy doesn't stand still
as they stumble backwards stunt for
example but the Precision shot doesn't
take those small movements into account
and has Jacob Fire towards where the
weak spot was initially it's at least
more manageable to pull off Precision
shots with full manual aim where you
quickly line up the shot yourself but
within the more crowded combat
encounters you don't always have the
time or space to do so as a whole the
design of the Callisto protocols combat
falls apart once you start facing swarms
of enemies who are coming at you from
all sides almost every aspect of combat
takes a lot of time and leaves Jacob
vulnerable switching weapon sees him
disassemble his current firearm and put
together whatever you're switching to
for instance and healing forces him into
a Crouch where he slowly injects himself
with a healing self the game is
encouraging you towards being selective
in your movements and actions carefully
managing your ammo and health in between
your attacks but you can't regularly do
that because enemies are constantly
trying to get into melee range and kill
you the grip device can create some much
needed space for yourself when facing
one or two enemies consists that can
only grab one enemy or object at a time
Effectiveness significantly drops in
larger crowds mechanically it feels like
the Callisto protocol wants to be a
methodical survival horror experience
but the design of enemy combat
Encounters in the latter half of the
game feels geared towards fast-paced
action
as the game races towards the finish the
Callisto protocol ratchets up the action
not the tension it had so carefully
curated in its opening moments fully
distancing yourself from the horror and
embracing the violently absurd it all
culminates in two final chapters filled
with challenging mini boss fights
sometimes almost back to back and a
frustrating final battle so detached
from where the closest protocol started
that it feels like you're playing a
completely different game the cluster
protocol had just become a third person
action shooter abandoning the core
concept it originally built its combat
around any of the enjoyable fear and
tension I had experienced in early going
had been gone for hours at that point to
be fair the Callisto protocol does
change things up for one level in the
latter half of the game trapping Jacob
in a series of tunnels filled with
biophages who are blind but sensitive to
noise thus encouraging you to approach
encounters with stealth instead of usual
swinging and shooting it's somewhat
enjoyable as a change of pace the clear
style protocols stealth mechanics aren't
anything to write home about though but
having a level exclusively focused on
them does at least feel satisfying to
break up the high octane action for a
spell the level only lasts for a short
time though and soon you're back to the
Lesser entertaining action Focus set
pieces from before
the crystal protocol is a very pretty
game when you pause between the biofage
Smashing to take a look at it when Jacob
gets his first good Glimpse at Jupiter I
was struck by just how beautiful The
View was character models are rendered
in incredible detail as well especially
the main cast the mocap work is at its
best in Sam whitworth's performance as
the antagonist Ferris whose face twists
with malicious Glee as he abuses Jacob
or takes on a cold air when discussing
concerns that don't impact him
whitworth's portrayal of ferris's slow
descendant to Madness is easily one of
the best parts of the game and I wish
the corrupt prison God had shown up in
the story as a recurring villain more
often than the three times he did the
sound design is also impressive with 3D
sound mapping the noises of a space so
that you can hear an enemy winding up
for an attack and identify every biofage
typed by the distinct noises they make a
huge Advantage given how dark or foggy
most of the Callisto protocols
environments are Jacob's weapons crunch
against the enemy bone with a twisted
snap and melt skin with a crisp Sizzle
as well providing a welcome order Curry
queue for when you hit your mark in the
Frantic melee of most fights the sound
design saved me on more than a few
occasions
overall the individual elements of the
Kalisto protocol are just at odds with
one another too often the enemy design
and melee Focus combat mechanics lend
themselves to these incredibly tense and
fun Close Quarters brawls when you're
only fighting against a couple of
targets at a time but the game regularly
locks you into frantic mosh pits or
frustratingly difficult boss fights
instead and despite the vocal talent and
mocap skill on display the Callisto
protocol story isn't all that
interesting save for an intriguing final
twist some genuine horror might have
improved the experience of the Survival
action game but the Callisto protocol
instead leans too far into absurd high
octane spectacle dampening the tension
and adulterating the narrative core of
the experience
foreign